[Music]
I don't know what it's like to live a
normal life where people just don't know
who you are
[Music]
to get out the car and not have everyone
stare here
Kylie Jenner in therapy for the first
time on the series premiere of her new
docu-series life of Kylie trying to
better understand living with Fame and I
just feel like for so long I've been
putting on this like different persona
to the world I'm kind of putting up a
version of myself to the world that
isn't fully me you're kind of presenting
not quite your whole self yeah if that's
criticized then you're still protected
yeah it doesn't really hurt me because I
know that that's not really me after
that therapy session Kylie got even more
candid with her BFF Jordan woods we're
always just there for each other and
he's super supportive so it really just
every day it's something new it's like I
see Kendal and like Bella and Hailey
they're made for this yeah which isn't a
bad thing but it's like that's not me I
don't want my picture taken it's like so
much pressure like I want to like grow
as a person the way I want to grow in
the path that I want to take you know
together her and I and all of our
friends we just always build each other
up no matter who it is
[Music]
you